it's difficult to imagine what there
might be left to salvage from this
destroyed neighborhood in western Aleppo
homes and a hospital shattered by bombs
dropped by what were believed to be
Russian warplanes in the town of [ __ ]
Russian Defense Ministry usually denies
it's involved it's the new frontline
close to Syrian opposition fighters main
supply lines in neighboring Italy
province their government forces are
advancing fast capturing towns and
villages and second largest city of
maarat al-nouman the violence has once
again driven families out of their homes
in to Syria's harsh winter I have
nothing with me we fled with just the
clothes we were wearing because of the
heavy bombing we escaped the air strikes
the air strikes were so intense that we
could only take the clothes we had on
our backs for people like Mohammad Sahib
concrete blocks like these in adlib city
is home for now the cold flows offering
little comfort for the children the
situation here is catastrophic because
we can't find a place to live in we are
here for families in this place where
there are no windows or doors you don't
even have water more than 3 million
people live in adlib half of them I'm
Toni displaced businesses are suffering
people say this simply cannot call the
trade is badly hit in the city the
displaced people don't have money to buy
anything they can barely find a place to
live what we need are places for these
people apartments or houses without
windows and doors are hosting four or
five families now can you imagine 30
people living in one room we can't even
find tents for the displaced at least 11
hospitals and health centers came under
attack from government forces backed by
Russian air power in Eid Lib last month
the surge in numbers of those displaced
has stretched the health workers to the
limits the most important challenge we
are facing is the security challenge for
us in the medical sector against our
facilities our and our medical
so we we in Sam's medicine American
Medical Society
we documented 82 attacks against the
healthcare services starting last April
for President Bashar al-assad the short
term goal is to secure Syria's main
highway that runs from north to south of
the country the larger plan is to
capture the entire province of Idlib the
last major stronghold of the rebels but
the people of ed Lib the mood remains
one of defiance
Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera